In the next Cycle, in Cycle 10, this instruction will be able to dispatch.
This is our ADD. And it's going to execute in Cycles 10 and 11.
So in Cycle 12 is going to try to write it's result. So in Cycle 11 nothing
really happens, other than the execution of these two instructions. But in Cycle
12 what's going to happen is this instruction is going to broadcast it's result.
So, we will mark that it grows as the result. We will find the register that
matches AD2 which is F6. And override the value of F6 with a new value.
Which is the minus 9.6 plus minus 2.5. So
it's going to be minus 12.1. So this is the value of AD2.
And now we're going to un-rename, this to, make future accesses read the new F6.
And no instructions was waiting for, know that this was the last instruction in
the statement so nobody was really waiting for this result.
But, this instruction is done now. So we can free this reservation station.
Now nothing will really happen until cycle 17.
In cycle 17, this multiply is finally going to broadcast its result.
We're multiplying 2.5 times 2.5, and then, you know, minus. And
that value goes into F0. So F0 is going to become whatever that result is,
we're not even going to even try to compute that.
It's going to be un renamed here. It's going to put that value over here. And
now the, divide is finally ready to go. And
we're going to free this reservation station. So finally, in cycle 18.
To divide is ready to go, it's been dispatched, at 40 cycles so
its going to be in cycle 58 that we finally produced that result. So
nothing really happens until cycle 58 at which point, this value is broadcast,
register F10 gets to grab that value, we unrenamed this,
we free this reservation station. We'll look at who is waiting for it,
but nobody is. And that concludes our example.